good evening members and officers of the
council and members of the public
um welcome to this meeting of
governments and audit committee uh just
a quick little bit of housekeeping um
the fire if the fire alarm procedure if
the fire alarm it's activated vacate the
offices via the stairs please do not use
the lifts assemble and Hawley Square on
the green officers will assist you and
advise when it is deemed safe to return
to the chamber
does anyone intend to film the meeting
if you say
nope fabulous
um restriction on mobile phones would
everyone Pleasant please ensure their
mobile phones are turned to silence and
that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls in the chamber while
the meeting is in progress
please note this meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public the
meeting will also be recorded and will
subsequently broadcast on the council's
YouTube channel
are there any members who wish to speak
under Council procedure rule 20.1
no and
moving on to a gender item one apologies
for absence I've received apologies from
counselor Lee's Braidwood and Whitehead
are there any other apologies for an
apologies for absence
yep
thank you
um
gender item two decorations of Interest
are there any Declarations of Interest
cool
agenda item three minutes of the meeting
held on 27th of July
um I'll just quickly pass over to Mr
Blundell to give a brief update on some
of the matters arising from those
minutes
thank you chair through you so at the
last committee there is a quest for a
couple of updates firstly for the
director of property to update the
committee on his plans uh to to address
some of the service issues around rent
and the like
um what I would say is that
his uh his approach and the strategy
that we've got for that is very much
still in development at corporate
management team level there's been a
request that's been put to us for some
more resources however we're looking at
it to make sure it is a sustainable
request which in theory it should be
however it's still to be agreed as to
the exact amount of resources that will
be made available
to the director of property in order for
them to address some of the issues that
are raised at the last committee meeting
so
um chair the intention is to invite the
director to come to the November meeting
of the committee at which point the
corporate management team will have had
the opportunity to
determine what the appropriate approach
is to address the issues that are
currently being experienced across our
portfolio secondly there was also a
request to have an update on ICT and the
head of ICT across the East Kent
Services partnership will also be in
attendance at that meeting there are two
items there I believe it was raised by
councilor Lee's the risks around home
working and also the approach that we've
got for disposal or recycling of ICT
equipment and the head of ICT will give
an update to the committee at its next
meeting
thank you chair
thank you and to approve the minutes of
the meeting held on 27th of July 2022
and you would have received a copy
attached to the agenda pack please can I
have a proposer and a seconder
proposed by councilor Duckworth
seconded by councilor towning unless I
hear any objection I will take these as
approved
Fab thank you moving swiftly onto agenda
item four quarter one review 20 20 to 22
to 23 treasury management and annual
investment strategy Mr blunder would you
please present the strategy report
thank you chair um not much to say it's
been a really quiet week in the
financial markets
um not much going on at all really
um in terms of this report it's actually
off the back of again of array a request
from the committee last time for us to
review our uh our investment strategy
it's
um this effective is a holding report so
it gives you an update of how we
performed in the first quarter of this
financial year again with a promise for
a further in-depth review of our
strategy at the November meeting as part
of the mid-year review
uh what I can say is that
um fortuitously I can't say it's based
on my grand judgment we're actually in a
reasonably good position because of the
uh the fact that we've kept most of our
investments short dated and liquid means
we stand to be able to benefit from the
significant uplift and interest rates
we're expecting to see so for the
council's perspective that's actually
beneficial for us all our borrowing is
fixed the external borrowing we have so
the interest rates won't vary that but
the Investments that we hold are
variable in nature we're already seeing
um on the bond market that rates are
getting close to five percent and we're
expected to see the interest rates for
the bank rates to get around five to six
percent over the next six months the
table that's presented in this report
was already out of date so what I do
have that I can share on the screen up
there with the now which has just been
received from our Treasury
management advisors this afternoon in
fact if I can get the right document
here
so this is let me try and find the right
forecast
so I'm just scrolling through here we
are
this is the
um the forecast that they're now
producing you can see it's got
yesterday's data and received today I'll
try and blow that up so it's a bit
easier to see
scroll across what we're looking at here
to the top top line that's the bank rate
the base rate that's set by the bank of
England they're forecasting that
interest rates will increase to four
percent by December maybe sooner than
that in my personal opinion but
um and then Peak at five percent from
the majority of
2023 before tapering back off by the end
of this time Horizon the three-year time
Horizon they've got there say that's
um
it's fairly speculative at the moment in
particularly the tale of that
that projection as to how quickly
interest rates go down if they do it too
quickly there's a risk that they would
further Stoke inflation which is
obviously the bank of England's primary
remitting concern if they do it too
slowly they risk
prolonging any sort of retrenchment in
the economy any depression in the
economy or lower growth or actually
recession
so I'm sure you've all been seeing
what's been going on in financial
markets for us an authority from a
treasury management perspective and this
is what we're looking at this report it
is actually quite beneficial because we
stand to generate more interest from our
investments that we hold so we've got 50
million pounds in our investment
balances at the moment if we can get
near to five percent if we would hold
that on average across the year
obviously that's two and a half million
pounds worth of investment income for
the council which is considerably higher
than what we've been receiving
previously if you recall we were getting
around 0.1 previously which was the base
rate so you know that's um that you know
that's a significant increase on the
rate of interest we'll be holding and
we're we're covered off from a debt
perspective
so we look at that in the round though
when we're considering our budgetary
position because there's other factors
that come into the play when we're
looking at the economic position at the
moment most primarily is inflation and
we're seeing that obviously with the uh
the impact on the value of sterling
which means lots of the goods that we
import namely uh fuel is is linked to
that price and our refuse Vehicles the
diesel costs are expected to go back up
the Matt Sanam as the Director or acting
director for that
director at the moment and we've just
been speaking early today around how the
the monthly fuel costs have peaked
around 50 000 pound per month they're
starting to come down but we expect that
they will now again begin to increase
again so it's a rounded picture for us
this report just solely focuses on
Treasury management activity we'll
continue to
um
obviously report to the committee uh as
of what impact that has on us going
forwards though I think it's it's most
likely that we will continue to keep our
investments liquid unless we can lock in
any of these higher rates for a longer
period of time I think it's unlikely
um that they'll go beyond the sort of
five percent Peak that we're looking at
so that would be an opportune time to
lock in and a longer rate but I think
the primary thing we'll be looking to is
continue with our strategy of internal
borrowing and what by that what I mean
is using our cash balances that 50
million pound to fund investment in the
capital program so rather than going out
to borrow from the market externally
to finance our Capital program we'll be
using those cash balances means it's
less available for investment and so we
won't necessarily get that rate of
return but equally
if that's what the bank rates will be
the rates of interest that we would
borrow at will be in excess of that so
there's always a margin so that will
continue to be our strategy at least for
the next quarter until we bring back an
update at the mid-year point to the
committee so appreciate there's a quiet
bit in this report but because of the
nature of where the markets have gone
over the last week or so and actually a
little bit before that Sterling was
starting to drop a little bit even
before Friday some of these uh figures a
lot of the figures are already out of
date but happy to take any questions on
the substance of the matter
[Music]
Council Yates
thank you Joe
um it was just a question so the 50
million pound kind of cash that we
invest we anticipate will be five or six
percent
um but our borrowing rate is much our
external borrowing rate is much lower
what roughly is the average external
borrowing rate in comparison
I've got it on here if I just try and
find the right table
bear with me unless
that will be on the borrowing section
right so I'm just trying to find what
our actual bot average borrowing rate is
I'm not sure if it's in this report but
if you get a section 4.2 see this was
looking at the end of June
so external borrowing rates if we're
going to borrow for 50 years from the
pwlb we're at 2.2 percent
um for rising to 2.7 of May and then 3.4
in June they're already now at five
percent so if we're looking to borrow
from pwlb even though Bank rates hasn't
increased because the Market's pricing
it in we'd already borrow at five
percent our actual average borrowing
rate is lower than that because of the
historic
um
rates that we've taken the loans out at
there is a figure in there somewhere but
I'm struggling to find it at the moment
uh Matt yeah I'm not sure if it's in
here
um if that's okay Council the eights I
will give you uh I'll be able to give
you and the rest of the committee
um a written response to what our
average rate is I can't say exactly what
it is offhand I'm afraid I think it's
usually in our reports but I can't seem
to pin it down and this report at the
moment
that's fine thank you very much
uh thanks so yeah I just want to check
my overall understanding of it so you
just the sort of headlines of the whole
thing are that um the changes in the
base rate did you say so it's expected
it's an extra 2.5 million income per
year on the council's Investments and
then this was Offset you said that the
other effects of the sorry was the
um extra cost of fuel which is 50 it was
the 50 000 amounts a month was up the
total figure yeah so that's um thank you
councilor just there were just some
figures for
um to exemplify the situation that we're
looking at
um so 2.5 million is enough it basically
is an indicator of the type of
investment income we can expect to
receive
um based on assuming 50 million pound
was the balance that we'd be holding
throughout the year that is a high
balance compared to historical levels
um partially due to the fact we've got
lots of money in from some of the
leveling up funds and the market Town
deal funds in advance
some of that will be spent and those
balances will start to drop so 2.5
million you're probably looking I would
say anticipating spend probably closer
to two maybe below that sounds
reasonable
um
if you were to look at our investment
balances have been around
um 50 million but we're getting 0.1
percent a bit north of that you'd be
looking around the sort of 500 000 pound
Mark as an average return I think is
what we're looking to get from our
investment income so there's somewhere I
would say between next year's budget
that we can look at all things being
equal a big chunk possibly a slug of
around about a million pounds worth of
additional investment income that's
probably a prudent estimate for us to
look at however
that's probably going to be gobbled up
pretty much immediately by a lot of the
pressures we're looking at that are
inflationary in nature so fuel is just
one of them our biggest inflationary
pressure will be on staff pay because if
you think we've got a net budget uh
figure of around about 18 million pound
18 19 million pounds
within that figure there's the council
overall I'm talking about budgets here
around the treasury
Staffing costs are around about are they
17
yeah 16 million pounds so if we're going
to have
um it's obviously subject to negotiation
when the Union's what the exact rate is
but you know if you see a a 10 increase
on that that's that's a comparable
uplift in the cost so I'm not expecting
this
um this to to clear all the decks of all
our financial pressures and that's just
Staffing cost as I've already alluded to
we've got inflation pressures Elsewhere
on energy
um Fuel and the like so it's very
welcome it's
um from a treasury management
perspective but I think the point I was
trying to make
um is that you've got to look at it in
the round although we're just
considering treasury management here
from a budget management perspective
this helps us but correspondingly some
of the market movements can be
detrimental to us at the same time
okay thanks
any other comments or questions from
members
no I have one
um section
3.9 around the approved limits
um yes if you could expand a bit more
about that as to how that happened and
if there's any consequences from this
error and what's being done to me yeah
um
this has it says and what this happened
twice what what we have is a six million
pound limit in terms of the amount of
money that we place with any one
counterparty another body that we invest
with so we put an investment with
another organization another fund of six
million pound the reason we set we set
those limits locally and the reasons we
do that is to basically manage and
spread our risks you don't want to put
all your eggs in one basket because
we've got 50 million pounds if I was to
see something that says oh this is going
to give us a 10 10 return let's put it
all in that effectively it's a little
bit like backing one horse uh race
because if that fun goes Belly Up you've
lost all the money so we're spreading
our money across multiple funds to
um mitigate the risk that one particular
investment goes under so that's to start
off that's the context of why we have
that six million pound limit in there
what happened in this instance was we
had money to that some six minute
deposited with a particular fund
we'd given them instructions that when
we receive interest on that fund is to
be paid to our main account our main
bank account what they did in error was
to credit that money to the investment
account so we had six million pounds of
the amount we've invested plus the
interest that they put onto the account
so in effect for a day or so well a week
actually between the 1st of June to the
8th of June and then from the first of
July to the 4th of July there was there
were instances where around about 5 000
pounds over that limit there's no
Consequence the authority apart for that
we are Duty bound to report to you that
we've breached our limits and in fact
we've we've got too much money with one
counterparty am I
um concerned no because it's a marginal
risk compared to the level that was
invested am I annoyed very and we've
spoken to the
um the company that's the manages this
investment and given them very clear
instructions that it's not to happen
again otherwise we'll be looking at
other arrangements in terms of where we
place our money effectively it's
administrative error on their behalf but
we obviously are Duty bound to report a
breach of the limit
Council Princeton
um just another thing to clarify my
understanding so is it right so we have
a 50 roughly 50 million pound investment
fund at the moment
and um I haven't read every word of the
report is that is there information in
the report about which investment funds
we're using and also to what extent has
that been subject to political
discussion in the past about which
where we are investing in the council's
funds
um I don't think it's appended to this
report but typically we do give a
breakdown of where the funds are
invested
um there's no political
um involvement in the placement of funds
that's purely delegated to staff and
myself and my team in terms of where we
place that money where the member
involvement comes in is when we're
setting our strategy to say the types of
institution that we want to use the
types of instruments that we want to use
what are risk appetite is so for example
we won't place it in line with our
strategy we won't place an investment
with anything that's below a certain
credit status to manage that risk we
also won't place an investment for
anything that's longer than a year or
typically longer than in excess of six
million pounds so those are the
parameters that that the committee
effectively sets and gives us a
framework to work with them but it is
delegated to officers to decide where we
we are we put them to be fair there are
obviously wider concerns as well well I
think it's fair to say the environmental
social governance gender is coming to
the four more and it's a really
difficult one to Circle to square in
terms of those considerations because
you can be investing with one fund that
looks squeaky Keen clean on the surface
but actually where are they then placing
their money subsequently could be some
less
desirable from a person a particular
perspective and also sometimes these
things can be
um
uh subjective in nature but we do try to
avoid
um funds that would be
um
could be I'm trying to think of the
right set of words could be considered
to be inappropriate for us to place with
so particular we've not got any
Investments with Russia for example or
we would we would avoid placing money
with any other particularly uh nation
states that have got
um questionable track records around
human rights and and the like
um or we you know but I think I don't
think we have in them in the past but I
know for example an authority I worked
with previously they had placements with
British American Tobacco because they
gave very good returns but then there's
questions about an authority placing
monies with an
um a firm that actually its objectives
are
um
uh in opposition to perhaps the the
objectives of of the council itself that
are looking to approve the health and
well-being but those are things so it's
a very long-winded way of saying the
framework is set by members when we set
the strategy and that's why that's an
important report but that's actually
delegated down to myself as section 151
and my team more widely and determine
which funds we place the money with on a
day-to-day basis
where exactly in the council is that he
said it's members setting an overall
strategy did you limit says this
committee or yes it comes to this
committee and then it goes to full
Council as well so it's part of the
budget setting process so it goes to
council every February as part of the
budget saying process so I believe
um assuming we're in the position it
will come to this Committee in November
as well the time yeah alongside the
mid-year report so
um that's the opportunity to have a look
at
um if there's anything in the strategy
that you don't particularly like so
sorry suggestion so you know in the
agenda for the next meeting would get
details for this which we could then
discuss yes okay great thank you very
much you're welcome
any other questions or comments yep
counselor Duckworth
we don't tend to use Brokers we tend to
place the money directly through a
portal that's cool it's um as a
portal called the ICD I can't remember
what the exact the acronym stands for
but that's a portal that allows us to
place directly with particularly money
market funds however we have been over
the last since we brought this report we
have been engaging with different
Brokers
um about three that we've considered and
that will be part of the update because
we'll need permission through the
committee for us to use those type of
brokerage firms
um so we'll give you an update then but
we have been exploring our options but
we haven't used
um brokers in the past
is that that's a that's an accurate
statement representative
no
[Music]
yes
yes
so that's sorry counselor to interject
but that's also what we rely on our
treasury management Consultants to
provide us some advice on so we engage
with link Asset Services they've
provided some training to the committee
in the past they give us a framework of
actually the types of
um uh the types of Investments we might
want to be looking at and also they've
got a color rating it's not quite a rag
rating but it's a color rating that
sells you how much you should put with
that type of
um that particular not just that type
that particular investment could be
Goldman Sachs it could be Nationwide
could be a one of the banks in Canada
and they'll tell you the amount that you
place with them and what's the
recommended duration is as well we can
breach that because that's just advice
but effectively
I don't think it would look very good if
it was order tid Pike Christine and her
team if we weren't following the advice
of our treasury management advisors and
we don't as a standard course we follow
that as a framework but the Brokers
you're correct they'll give us some
additional information to lay over layer
over the top of that advice that we
already receive
councilor duck for
thanks for so so on the Brokers
um and
to do with what council Hopkinson was
saying can you get ethical Brokers that
would help you
to choose ethical Investments I'm not
sure about I might bring he's shaking
his head we can't get ethical Brokers
but they will advise on whether a fund
has ethical credentials
um typically obviously you you will be
taking or accepting a lower rate of
return not always but typically when
you're you're investing in those because
some of the less ethical Investments
tend to generate higher rates of return
and that's where the conflict comes
because this is a treasury management
activity and our primary responsibility
is to get the best yield by actually
keeping the investment secure and liquid
within the framework that sit for sets
and the legislation sets it doesn't
actually bring in ethical considerations
but that is something we're mindful of
but when we're looking at Investments we
are we are what I'm I'm set and the
statute of responsibility our primary
responsibility has to make sure we don't
um lose the council's money and that
we're getting a good return but we try
to look in a holistic manner so what I'm
trying to say probably in a pretty
clumsy way is if there was an investment
out there that's vanilla investment
hasn't got ethical credentials but is
secure it's liquid and has given me a
good rate of return I've got to consider
how big is the differential compared to
an ethical investment and if it's too
much it's very difficult to justify that
and wouldn't get over the tests that
were sort of set around the the
potential code the treasury management
code and all the other
statutes and Frameworks we have to
follow
Matt is there anything else you'd like
to add to that no no
yeah
and the recommendation is that the
committee notes the report please may
have a proposal and a seconder proposed
by councilor Yates seconded by councilor
Hopkinson
unless I hear any objections I'll take
this as approved
Fab a gender item five uh the quarterly
internal update reports I'll now
introduce you to Christine Parker for
the report
thank you Joe yes before you is the
quarterly update report I'd like to take
you through the highlights of that
report starting with page 25 if I made
the table at paragraph two
this shows the five key areas that were
reviewed During the period and gives you
the number and criticality of the
recommendations made in each of those
reviews
the pages through 25 through to 30 then
report the executive summary from those
individual reviews that have been
concluded and the key areas found both
to be working well
and alongside those the opportunities or
the areas
identified for internal control
improvements
as is normal practice those once
completed the progress report for each
of those will be brought back to a
future meeting for the committee so that
you can see how well the recommendations
have been progressed
talking of which page 31 details the
progress reports undertaken in the
period and the matters really to draw
your attention here are the three so
equality and diversity remains a limited
assurance and there are four high
priority issues
um where I think more timely review is
required here you'll see from the detail
in the committee report that we haven't
received any sort of update on when we
can expect these recommendations to be
implemented that said obviously there's
been quite a lot of change in the
responsibilities in that area so I'm
sure it will be something that will be
picked up in due course
um
the playground's review again uh whilst
it does sit at a reasonable Assurance
for you members there are four
outstanding high-risk recommendations
that are yet to be actioned and again no
revised dates were suggested to us in
that progress report process
conversely whilst and the street
cleansing does remain as previously
reported as no Assurance there is a very
positive direction of travel here that
we can talk to you about so since
presenting the original review to
Committee in March management comes in
the detail do include updates now for
completions for new revised dates there
are the four critical and the one high
priority recommendation yet to be
actioned but we do have
um
officers from with responsibility uh
here who can give you a detailed update
but as I'm reporting that things are
moving quite quickly forward and and a
lot of the recommendations hang off one
thing which is the service stance that's
being approved once that thing is in
place and then a lot of the others fall
out of that so we can hear if you've got
questions about that in shortly
moving forward page 35 details the plan
completion to the 30th of June and just
to update to the end of August plan
completion was at 35 against a target of
42 percent
um and that just varies across the
partnership
um so we're not overly concerned there
page 46 details the areas that we've
reported previously to you with lower
levels of assurance that are yet to be
followed up some of those are now
allocated and are work in progress so
you can look forward to seeing those
progress reports at a future committee
meeting and then page 47 is our
performance metrics for the audit
partnership again to the end of June
we're nearly at the end of the second
quarter already
um so that concludes my presentation
members the report is for noting and I'm
happy to invite any questions as I say
especially as we've got colleagues here
who
maybe we're able to take any updates
forward for you thank you
councilor Garner
thank you yeah thanks thanks for the
report yes I would like to ask um
a couple of questions about the street
cleansing update you gave
um obviously I think most of us will
agree that of the number of areas we
contacted by residents and which are
high profile my resident Street
cleansing is is quite near the top so
it's important that we do get on top of
our street cleansing activities
so you've
you said you you have more confidence
that things are happening and that
things are going to be improving
um based around service standards being
approved a future cabinet
so I could could I hear just a little
bit more about why
how sure we are the service standards
are going to be approved at cabinet
which cabinet that's going to be
and a bit more about why you have more
confidence in some progress being made
because some of these actions have been
outstanding for a number of
multiple months thank you thank you
through the chair as the Director
responsible is that too my right I'm
going to ask him to give you an update
thank you
I can't comment on why it didn't move
forward previously all I can comment on
is why it's going to move forward now
and that's I'm now involved in the
process and it's now my responsibility
to take it Forward I have a draft set of
service standards with me which will be
going not with me here but I they are
with me to sign off on I will be taking
those back to CMT not next week but the
week after for discussion once they're
signed off by CMT they will be put on
the next available agenda that I can for
cabinet so in that respect I can confirm
as Christine said that they are in there
they have been taken forward they are
with me to sign off and take through CMT
um I think you'd agree that you know the
zonal cleansing is working it's seen
improvements in various areas I think
the public generally of of light that
that zonal type of cleansing operation
it gives us more flexibility it gives us
the opportunity to do the Deep cleans
and hit the areas where we need to when
we need to so that's where we are at the
moment
I will I will just add up I agree with
you but there has been a note
a noticed Improvement in some areas
um so I don't want to sound completely
negative and I will pass on that um
part of my board is the car park next to
the railway station in Saint Peter's
Park Road which is the bane of my life
with people contacting me there was a
noticeable Improvement there a couple of
weeks ago when there was obviously a hit
squad went in there and cleaned it up so
thank you for that
um it will need to be doing again very
soon
thanks a lot
counselor can you put your mic on
please sorry sorry
uh
helps to work forever attacking Council
bayford because
people have no respect for that area
it's right beside a medical center
uh we have cleaned up the car park the
Old Coach car park ourselves
something needs to be looked at more
closely in the clemency of that area
uh I mean I'm quite happy to organize
BCU there and having a chat uh because
you look it's it's it's it's it's a
really eyesore and especially in the
summer
because along Palm Bay Avenue is a lot
of free parking
and you have visitors coming there it
certainly doesn't give the right
impression of us as standard people you
know and it needs to be looked at they
do go and tidy it up but I don't think
they do it as often as they claimed to
do it
thank you
all I can say is once the new revised
service standards are in place with
regards to Cleansing there is a plan
that as part of that process the
supervisor of vehicles as they drive
around than it will be taking snapshots
as they drive which will then give us
sort of stills of the districts and how
clean the streets are and how clean the
various areas are and if that's one of
the areas they're cleaning it's one of
the areas that they'll pass so we'll get
pictures back those pictures that are
taken won't be being assessed by the
cleansing team or that service they'll
be farmed out to other officers within
TDC there will be a list of around 20
different officers within the council
that will review those images so if we
find that there's hot spots where
they're regularly taking pictures and
the rubbish is building up they'll be
targeted more frequently
uh cancer tanning
the other thing is are you familiar with
Princess wall That's the top of uh uh
the the the the the the cliffs
there are absolutely no bins along there
I had rubbish I mean if they're little
bits people can't put their rubbish away
it's as simple as that and that's
something that you're you know through
your progress and through your appraisal
of the area that you ought to have a
look at because it's because the lorries
actually go along the top of that road
so it's not that they're having to make
a special effort to go there to collect
the rubbish it's there
okay thank you
councilor right
thank you chair
um
we in birchington we've got two
recycling Depots which up until recently
were overflowing and we suspect flight
tipping we actually I'd like to say
thank you
um we actually got the signage moved so
that people could see it as they drive
in
and it has died down a little bit
especially when they've been told that
people are taking photographs of the
rubbish could you give me the figures of
anybody that you actually caught
through that Intel and were prosecuted
because I think that's the only way
you'll stop it make an example and Go
the whole way a thirty thousand pound
fine will stop a lot of fly tipping in
those tips
I'll get the figures but I don't have
them to hand but I will look into it for
you as part of this and come back
councilor Duckworth
I see you undertaking work on the
complaints modeling monitoring and um
can I suggest that we need a clear flow
chart on the planet District Council
website because I think if complaints
aren't resolved I'm not sure that
residents really know what to do in that
situation they get I know there's a
complaints form and they get a reference
number but sometimes that's it if it
doesn't get resolved and this is
something
that it may do later on the line but um
I know I know specific residents for
which it hasn't
and I certainly can't see a flowchart on
the website
thank you I'm sure access and Clarity
and helping customers know how to
complain more form part of the scope of
that review which we'll report back
thank you
councilor Yates
thanks Jeff
um just to clarify the funny Lotto item
um is has done it Lotto now closed and
is it no longer operational and uh
second question just about
um CCTV and what are the next steps then
for the council to resolve that specific
item that's been highlighted thanks
do you want me to answer that yeah
that's fine sure I was just waiting for
you to direct it to me but that's fine I
didn't want to steal your thunder but
I'm happy to answer it
um Planet Lotto is operational it had to
close for a period of time because there
wasn't an active license holder in place
um
I am currently the license holder for
the thanet lottery and we're looking to
appoint at least or have appointed at
least one other director to avoid that
happening again
um it arose because uh there was a
situation where the previous license
holder that was a member of the
corporate management team was no longer
actively employed by the council and as
such we had to suspend the lottery for a
period of time
um we've
um uh we've had our operation I think it
was appeared about seven to eight weeks
was it was close close suspended for
no
um
yeah it's been operational again since
then and I don't anticipate
um we'll see that problem again in the
future because as I said we'll have
um further license holders in place so
to say if I was no longer at the council
someone else would be able to step in
and
um provide those license holder
responsibilities I'm not able to answer
the CCTV questions if I can defer that
to you Christine
thank you thank you for the question yes
indeed um we brought the original
um review of CCTV with no Assurance to
the previous meeting and I'm pleased to
say we were able to give a verbal update
on the evening and it is on page five of
our gender pack under the minutes
um and if I just read to you CCTV had
had no level of assurance due to lack of
privacy zones on the cameras among other
areas among other issues sorry
management had advised that a number of
the greed recommendations had since been
implementing implemented including
correcting the Privacy zones so the
really critical risks have been
addressed by the time we brought that to
Kmart committee the work in progress for
the follow-up
um I can't guarantee it'll be completed
for the December meeting but it would be
in our interest to bring that back to
you and confirm that we have
independently tested all of those
recommendations are in indeed in
implemented and effective and would look
forward to revising that Assurance for
you thank you thanks
any other questions or comments from
members
no I've got a couple
you know just to spice things up
um going back just to the uh the planet
Lotto
um
one of the findings was that there was
um 50 000 pounds there not yet
distributed is there plans in place for
that to start being distributed in a
transparent way to community projects
uh we did have a plan during some of the
lockdowns the the intention was to
allocate the money to some of the food
banks in the district but at the time it
was um
there wasn't a need which sounds
surprising but the food banks were
sufficiently funded at that time
um
there isn't a current active plan to my
knowledge unless uh Matt you can update
consequently if this pinned any further
not a plan per se but we did also match
a 2 000 pound contribution from the
unions too thank you I can't remember
what the cause was it was Ukraine
refugees so we we yeah
against the union contribution so money
has started to be distributed but
obviously
um 50 000 still a significant amount of
money there is a plan in terms of having
a conversation internally about who will
be the lead on that now moving forward
and I think it comes back to the changes
in the organization and the capacity to
be able to deliver it but it will then
be allocated in an open and transparent
manner to good causes
great and in terms of the quality and
diversity and
most of it is obviously was allocated to
staff which are no longer here have we
now got a lead person to drive that
forward because it's quite important
I'm almost following on for Matt's
similar themes she may want to Duck and
Cover but um it is sitting with Samira
but she has a very wide remit and right
at the top of that is the implementation
of the Imo's recommendations but it the
aquatican diversity previously sat with
Estelle Culligan so Samira and I will be
sitting down to have a look at that at
some point in the near future but
um yeah it's a bit of a juggling out
because of what's going on at corporate
management team at the moment we are
awaiting the restructure of the
corporate management team because we're
all stretched a bit thin at the moment
but we don't I don't disagree is a an
important priority that does need
addressing
please fabulous and
um one other question which kind of
overlaps a little bit of that one but
also the work done on
um the recruitment process so the piece
of work on the website about recruitment
process and I know previously there was
an audit on website accessibility so I
just wonder was that touched on in terms
of our recruitment process how can we
make ourselves more accessible for
people with additional needs and also
something to consider has the councilor
the considered trying to become a
disability confident employer as well so
I just thought that might be something
it's not necessarily the right Forum
here but it might be something to look
into
thank you um the scope of the review
um is probably broader than that that's
shown at paragraph 2.3.1 very much
though about our internal procedures
around
um
selecting the best candidates
the equality and diversity item
obviously as you say collect correctly
it links in and I think that this was
probably the first review we've looked
at on the sort of Eve recruitment
process as well and I think with the
digital enhancements I'd like to think
the answer to your question is yes
everything is is made much more
accessible clearly it's about placement
isn't it and making sure that those
vacancies are um
made available
so yeah I think
there's always more that can be done
isn't there but there is good strategies
in place for that thank you
great
um the recommendation is that the
or if I've lost it
um can we see um notes the reports can I
have a proposal and a second off
and propose if I counselor right second
if I cancel a Duckworth thank you moving
on to the annual governance report I
will introduce you to Samira Khan who
will introduce the report
thank you chair first of all please
accept my sincere apology for the
lateness of this report which was beyond
my control the report should have been
with yourselves in July but it's here
now for your comments the annual
Governor statement is basically as your
voice is a statutory document which is
which we are required as a local
authority to produce and explain the
process and procedures which enables the
council to carry out these functions
effectively a chance to the report there
is an Annex which is the draft statement
for the council which members are asked
to approve the report is presented
basically for the year
2021-22 which is the the last year from
April to March and the
uh in the lines of doing the annex
report I've had to draw in some of these
sources such as the minutes from the
various working parties committees and
so forth which is all set out in the
Annex in particular I like to draw
members attention to Pages four which
sets out the internal audit work
undertaking the report was presented to
yourselves in July last year um sorry
July just gone which basically gave you
some of the work
for the last year
then the page eight
um talks about the corporate fix for the
for the council which includes the
limited resources that we have and the
disciplinary and the grievance
procedures and matters that which are
still ongoing this year but it sets out
in sort of brief details as to how where
we are with that uh then page eight
talks sort of sets out the complaints
that the local government
ombudsmans are actually dealing with the
moment for the year
2021-22 they had a total of 30
complaints from various species and so
forth out of which only one was upheld
under the category of male
Administration and Injustice and then
one way they was also same category but
they classified that the they received a
satisfactory response from the
organization so it was upheld which is
which is remarkable after 30 complaints
that the local government Ombudsman
dealt with
um they I then set about the IMR reports
and its recommendation which is from
page 10 onwards
members are asked to note the report and
any comments they wish to make I'm happy
to take any comments um and the
reporters are set up before you thank
you
Council Garner
thank you yeah I'd just like to ask
about the complaints piece that you
outlined
30 complaints received on one one up or
two uphill but one with no further
action is that is that a significant
change
or is that something that you would
expect
that sort of percentage of complaints
being made that are actually upheld
which is very small I mean
is there maybe a trend of um
how shall I say malicious
complaints being made do you see a trend
through there is a common theme of the
type of complaints that have been made
that are not being
that are inappropriate not being upheld
just wonder is that what you would
expect that small amount of uphill
complaints
thank you
just to have two complaints which are
held normally local ombudsmen draw quite
a lot into it and with the number of
complaints that we've had I think it's a
very good turnout for one where they
have held and then the other one they
felt that the local Authority dealt with
it appropriately so effectively it's
literally one that they upheld so yes
from my experience it's a good turnout
yeah sorry that's done it is good I
understand that but if
of all the other complaints I mean if
you've got a view as to whether they
were there was some malicious complaints
being made in a program is there some
sort of
I don't know publicity needed to educate
people who are making complaints
inappropriately
it seems quite a lot of people are
making complaints that are being
dismissed without any
without any basis
foreign
I don't know the actual nature of the
complaints individually because I was at
least pre-day to me so I don't know the
each one of them but I can assure you
that at the moment we are inundated with
a lot of complaints some of them can be
rotation some of them can be quite
unreasonable and they do sometimes go to
the Ombudsman
um I'm happy to if you want more details
I'm happy to dwell into the data that
I've got and give you a written response
if that helps
yes please thank you
Council Yates thanks Joe
um just on that item that counts the
Garner raised
um are we allowed to know the details of
the
the male Administration and Injustice
that was upheld on the umbuds the
ombudsman's complaint on page eight
and if so can I have the detail
um I will check on that one as I said
it's previously so I don't know if we
have the public published I'm sure we
can well yeah I'm sure we can I will
find the information and I'll come back
to you in that concept thank you
any other questions or comments
no good I found one typo
um
under external audit reported that Mr
Grant Thornton I mean I didn't realize a
natural person
um I was quite oh my god I've got the
big guy here
um yeah just the Mr Grant Thornton so
that was it thank you sorry Grandma
um
so the recommendation is that the
committee agrees the draft annual
governance statements
um
can I get a proposal in a second
proposed by councilor towning and
seconded by councilor Hopkinson thank
you
moving on oh sorry unless I hear any
objection I'll take that as approved
great
um moving on to agenda item 7 risk
management
um Chris will introduce this report
thank you chair uh just for a little bit
of context before I hand over to Amy
who's our insurance and risk lead
officer at the council who's actually
done all the hard work in presenting and
producing this report
so at the last committee we presented to
you the updated risk management strategy
which effectively is the the framework
that we're going to follow that how we
will do risk management here at thanet
District Council we made a good start on
implementing that but we haven't had all
the returns back in line with our new
format and style of reporting as such
this report is following the previous
style of reporting that you've seen so
it's not strictly in line with our our
latest update risk management strategy
it follows the format that you will have
seen previously but the future committee
uh reports will be presented in line
with that updated
framework that we're following so we're
just stuck a little bit between stalls
at the moment so that's why it might
look like it's not changed that much the
only other the only real sort of change
it was is the work aim is done she has
included or enhanced or expanded the
list of risks that you'll see in the
appendix so those are the risks that
don't meet the the highest rating score
and they've largely been derived from
some of the service risk registers but
I'll um without further Ado I'll hand
over to Amy to give you an overview of
what the quarterly risk update is
showing
thank you Chris hello all
um yes I just follow on from what Chris
said yeah we haven't made some really
good progress in the new risk registers
but as Chris alluded to unfortunately
the new strategy is in between stalls so
next time we see you in November we're
hoping to present something a lot more
engaging and relevant for you so we're
just going to present it in the current
format and hopefully wow you next next
time I see you
um so going on to the corporate risks
they haven't changed none of the
corporate risks have actually changed in
their scoring since last time although
there are some updates on them so what I
plan to do is just give you a brief
overview on the updates on the corporate
risks and then take you through the
annex dress which is the new part of the
report I think we did touch on briefly
last time um but it'd be good to bring
that alive and what we're hoping to do
is have an engaging atmosphere here so I
can take away your comments to the
service areas and come back next time
and give you some answers to the
questions which I won't have for you
immediately and that's what I'm hoping
for this sort of Engagement between
ourselves and yourselves in the g a
committee so just looking at the
corporate risk and I know we did spend
some time on this last last time we were
here
um I just wanted to touch on Cyber
attack now funnily enough just before I
came into this meeting I had a report
from our brokers in respect of cyber and
the market has hardened significantly
and I think we've alluded to that before
however it is quite serious now that we
are going to struggle to get Cyber
insurance now luckily in insurance and
actually we've been talking about it for
some time with our partners at ICT we've
realized that it's going to be quite
difficult for us to get any sort of
cyber cover so what we've been doing is
looking to mitigate that risk by looking
at risk management in terms of cyber so
we are starting to look at Risk
Management Solutions with our Brokers
and with various different organizations
not just with the Brokers we've looked
at risk management Partners which is one
of our insurers and our main insurers
which is Zurich Municipal we are going
to have further updates to that but
rather than looking to ensure ourselves
against cyber attack we're actually
looking to stop the source of these
before they actually happen so they say
prevention is better than cure and
that's what we're looking to do so
further updates on that but I do believe
going forward cyber Insurance isn't the
way forwards for us and it's going to be
about strengthening our systems and
looking at our risk management
techniques and mitigations that we can
put in place before these cyber attacks
happen
another update that I've got and please
feel free afterwards to ask me any
further questions on the other corporate
risk but I believe some of them have
remained quite static the other one and
I do believe we've have updated recently
is the limited resources and as you're
probably aware we're commencing the
budget Bill process for 23 to 24 and
that's against the high the background
of high inflation increased prices which
I'm not going to wax lyrical on because
of course we've spoken about this in
this meeting of course it does create
uncertainties and allowing the council
to set a balanced budget especially with
ongoing unknowns around government
Financial finance settlements so as in
Prior years this means the accounts are
restricted to setting a meaningful
budget for one year and three scenarios
that can be put forward through the
medium-term financial strategy a budget
position cannot be guaranteed due to the
various factors outside of the council's
control
and I do believe the other one that I
did want to update you on was just Birds
four and five because I think this has
been updated the birth insulation and
work commenced in June due for
completion at the end of September I'm
not sure if we've got any other updates
on that at the moment
um the birth customer Aggregates will
fit in so we fit an aggregate conveyed
to the birth following completion of the
birth installation these delays have
resulted in Financial Risk to the
council due to extended birth outage and
Associated contractual costs and I'm
sure you can ask questions about that in
a moment so that's the big corporate
risks and I wanted to touch on today but
what I would like to draw all your
attention to is the annex and this is
the bit of work that we discussed last
time and this is the thing that I really
want to draw your attention to because
these These are actually the risks that
are as service risk these are the risks
that we're facing every day in our
day-to-day working throughout different
service areas and you can see actually
throughout the annex the the actual
share
um variety of risks that you've got here
so you've got everything from sort of
procurement risk through to service risk
from operational we've got health risks
and so on so forth
so what the aim here is is these are a
lot of these are future risks these are
emerging risks a lot of these are risks
that we know are coming so as I
mentioned last time for who whoever was
here last time we're looking to be more
proactive so rather than wait for these
risks to actually happen let's start
doing something about them now let's
start discussing them now let's put
things in place let's actually watch our
mitigations work for us let's not just
wait for it to happen and then do
something about it so we have got some
increasing risk coming up like with
burial space which is the first one
um now I'm sure you don't you guys don't
need me to take you through each risk
individually but these are the ones that
we are discussing at service level these
are the ones we need to bring to your
attention I need you to care about these
I need you to want to be engaged with
these because then I can go away and ask
those questions do the service areas and
ask them what they're doing challenge
their mitigations work out what we can
do going if it's not working let's do
something about it so the burial space
one I think is quite a pressing problem
I think we can all agree
um there is some plans in place to reuse
ancient Graves now there is a bit of
flux at the moment over the crematorium
which may impact on this um sadly and
I'm sure that's something that the
service area will work on but I think
right now the crematorium has got some
issues in terms of the management with a
sad passing of the crematorium manager
so that's something that we will be
visiting with them but it's potential
now not until the next risk registers go
out
um again looking at things like the
reduction in Supply base and funnily
enough just before this meeting I was
actually talking to Gemma who's actually
um one of the managers over in
procurement and this is something
especially with the financial situation
that we've got out in the markets there
is a chance that reduction in Supply
base could mean that we're not able to
actually complete the right procurement
methods it could be that when we're
going out to Tender we actually haven't
got enough people to Tender and it's
actually something that I'm seeing in
the insurance Market as well we went out
to Tender for summer Insurance products
last year and because of reduction in
Supply base was one policy we only had
one person actually once put in a bid
and so if we're seeing that in the
insurance Market which technically has a
lot of bidders in there then we're going
to see that across the board so gem has
been looking at mitigations for that
um Jackie Baker's
um Park which is something of a service
business now this has um there has been
some issues with this building The Reef
had fallen in and so on so forth the
building has been fenced off to stuff
access I know that Open Spaces are
working hard to mitigate that risk but
there is a longer term plan needed for
this particular area
um and we go on to have some monitoring
now this is something I'm sure you guys
are probably already aware of his halves
and we know that a few years ago this
was something that really to deflect as
a council what's been happening is is
that although we've been able to monitor
halves the way that houses moved on and
we're now looking at things like whole
body vibration monitoring it means that
the way that we did monitor halves is
maybe not as effective as we wanted it
to be so we are looking now to mitigate
this before it becomes a problem we have
got a lot of people on what's called
zero points so they can't actually use
any vibrating tools and that obviously
means that that is a pressure on the
service we need people to operate
vibrating tools but of course if they're
on zero points they're not allowed to so
there's a balance there between what the
service needs to deliver actually
People's Health as well so it's quite a
fine balance so this is something that
we need to find a solution to and from a
service delivery perspective it can have
a big impact
um and then we go down to the last three
you'll be pleased to know
um external funding on regeneration I
think we've actually maybe covered that
off today as well
um a little bit so I won't go on too
much about that
um the next one's an interesting one
actually so the risk of harm to the
public from uncontrolled use of powered
watercraft now we live in a coastal area
um you know these are the sorts of
things that necessarily you wouldn't
think about on a corporate risk review
actually this is something from a
service perspective is actually quite
serious
um they have now recruited a beach and
coastal manager which is great Lee
search now started they've got the water
youth group so I think this one we will
probably look to update more fully in
the next one it potentially could be
that this will drop off of there now
that we've recruited the new beach and
coastal manager the final one is one of
my favorites because it's something
that's quite close to my own job which
is the algae we have had some very large
what we call Azure catastrophic claims
come in from sleeps on algaes we've
actually defended all of them
successfully and one of them was a
million pound claim we've actually
defended all of these claims
successfully because we've been able to
demonstrate that we inspect the areas
and that we have astringent and very
good
um cleaning schedule in place however
there isn't there is an argument here
that we don't clean these areas because
actually by cleaning we could be
inviting claims we could be inviting the
liability
um so this is again this is something
that's going on and we are actually
taking risk management advice from our
insurers and our response from Partners
on this so again you know we're looking
to provide additional signage
unfortunately again signage can actually
give you admission of liability because
you're saying oh you could slip over so
you're telling the public they could
slip over is that an admission in
liability the the jury's out on that at
the moment and again we're still
investigating that with our risk
management Partners I expect to see that
one drop off eventually because given
that if we tell people it's going to be
slippery and don't walk on it you'd
think that they would unfortunately
that's not always the case but we have
now set a precedence with our insurers
to say that we can repudiate these
claims so again that helps us to drop
down the risk so those are the risks
that we've got on Annex one
um and that's that's pretty much it what
we expect to see next time is not just
the same risks on here but we're looking
to update the mitigations that's just
about saying okay we've still got the
same risk we might still have the same
risk why I'm hoping to let you guys know
is actually what we're doing about it
the updates on the mitigations what
lessons we've learned and what we're
looking to take forward and then take
questions from you back to the service
areas what are your concerns on our risk
management what would you like us to see
to be done
um and that's pretty much me presenting
your risk management report thank you
thank you Amy are there any questions or
comments
councilor Garner
thank you thank you Amy
um and I do look forward to the new
format report although I have to say you
have bought this alive with your
presentation so thank you for that
um I did just want to ask one question
about the
pspo risk relating to a risk of harm to
the public being hit by
watercraft such as jet skis and there's
going to be the enforcement officer
employed
from next year now I assume that that
would be an enforcement officer covering
the whole of the pspo so that's not that
that doesn't just cover obviously
um being hit people jet skis and
watercraft there are a number of other
things covered by the pspo like
um
unlawful Vehicles parked by the coast
and
hopefully unlawful
littering and stuff like that so would
would that
um enforcement officer cover a number of
other areas
apart from the jet skis I can pass this
over to Matt who's much more well-versed
in this type of situation
he said it could be reduced by the
recruitment of a p of uh pspo so it's
not necessarily that we go down that
road it's looking at opportunities to
mitigate the risk on the foreshore and
it's just an opportunity for mitigating
the risk but yes you're right ultimately
if we if we were to recruit an officer
if that's what we looked at doing they
would have a much broader remit than
just managing jet skis they would be
looking at cyclists barbecues all sorts
of things that happen on the coast and
realistically it's never going to be one
officer managing the whole of the coast
what we'd have to do is look at
opportunities to how we can finance that
because they're not self-financing those
type of resources as you can imagine
because they couldn't possibly issue
enough fines to be able to cover their
own salaries so it's just about this is
an opportunity to look at why a wider
options with regards to to the coast
so can
will there be an opportunity for us to
be involved in that assessment
of um how best to enforce the pfpo
please
I think ultimately what would end up
happening is if we go down that road if
it was for example taking forward as
part of the budget process then It
ultimately it's going to be in the
papers that are going to end up going in
front of cabinet so it will be available
for discussion as part of that process
realistically we're not at that point at
the moment it was something that was
explored as an opportunity previously
probably about six months ago leading
into the summer season to try and manage
it and it does come down to some extent
to affordability moving forwards yes I
think there will be an opportunity to
have a wider discussion about what that
might look like and what sort of things
would be the focus and priority of those
type of resources
counselor right okay
um thank you for saying that you're
going to look into the the cyclists
along the foreshell with all due respect
at the moment
um I have a beach hut with with all
Jewish but yes there are good cyclists
there are some very ignorant cyclists
but I think one of the larger problem at
the moment is scooters
um because they seem to think that they
ruled the roads and also there's I've
noticed that there's an increase in
mobility scooters but they're not people
that need mobility scooters there are
now double decker mobility scooters that
are riding along in procession and they
are definitely not not disability they
these are people buying mobility
scooters
um one thing that I'm not sure if
anybody realizes I did look into the
schools at the mobility side when you
purchase the mobility scooter it is
actually registered with the dvla and
you are given number plates but the
number plates are optional
and I'm wondering if we could do
something about that
my initial response would be if you're
talking about a vehicle on the road it's
going to be a police matter so from an
enforcement perspective it would be for
the police to manage um whether it's
something that we can raise as an issue
through
um you know our contacts with the police
is is is an option But ultimately you
are talking about enforcement matters
and to some extent it's the same with
the scooters the scooters are used on
public highways now and it's they become
a police matter as a result of it
thank you chair
um I'm mindful that this is GNA not
scrutiny uh or OSP
um however
and as such we should be looking at the
risks and the controls that the council
has in place now we're managing those
risks however if this particular risk is
um something that the committee is has
um
significant concern from
um the monitor officer May correct me if
I'm wrong but the committee has the
ability to request that cabinet consider
it's that is that right yeah so if you
wanted to
um if you wanted to raise this risk
further off the back of this committee
it could be a recommendation to to
Cabinet to consider it
Castle Yates
thanks chair I've just got um
three points I'd say them so I believe
that's okay
um thanks uh just just uh feedback to
Amy on the on the algae on the
yeah situation
um
I I just
I'm a bit concerned that if we focus too
much on the risk and not about the other
side which is the benefit to the
community
um then you might have a situation where
like hundreds or maybe a thousand
residents are upset because they can't
no longer no longer go swimming at
Whirlpool tidal pool because they don't
because then the there's no pressure
washing
um so I think we need to take
the risks with the benefits and that's
definitely a health benefit that um lots
of our residents do take up
um it wasn't really a question but just
more of a comment
um
first so the second point is just birth
four and five which is a question it was
mentioned about the conveyor belt being
installed
on on the birth on the pontoon I'm just
wondering who pays that is that TDC or
is that Brett's
um
my understanding is that that's a
barrette's cost in terms of the actual
conveyor belt and the installation of it
um
in terms of the project itself it's it's
it's nearing completion
um as as you know cancer Yates and
um all substantial Works need to be
completed by Friday
um the end of this month because that's
the the period of time that the
permissions are in place for
um yeah not
much more to say was there anything else
that you wanted to ask in relation to
four five apart from the conveyor belt
no okay
I just had one more sorry
um it's about homelessness and Clause
5.7
um it mentions this one million pound
Financial pressure we're currently
facing I think it's fair to say that
this winter is going to be incredibly
hard for a lot of our residents
um and I can only see this pressure
increasing and I don't really see
how we mitigate it
um as a council I think the mitigations
we can put in place are
um yeah
yeah my question I guess would be are
there any risks uh is that is there any
mitigation we can do
um which would have a serious impact and
if not I think it is fair for cabinet to
consider this as a serious risk
um as you mentioned for the other point
uh
Chris so yeah
so in terms of the mitigation there's a
couple of angles you can look at it
firstly Financial mitigation in terms of
trying to get the cost down of the
project one way we're looking at doing
that is through Foy house through once
that is in place that will mean we'll be
able to house families at a lower cost
than the placements they're currently
using obviously that doesn't
um
tackle the number of households that are
presenting as as homeless to address and
mitigate that we're actually considering
that the corporate management team
next week on Tuesday at our regular
meeting
as part of the budget setting process
for this financial year for 2223 we
included an extra 400 000 pound in the
budget there's some flexibility as to
how we can use that and we'll be
considering whether
um if some additional Staffing Resources
into the service will will actually help
us manage down those numbers in terms of
further preventative work that we can do
to stop how houses or homelessness
becoming an increasing problem but it is
a demand-led service it's one of those
what it's it's a service
that we've got less scope for sort of
traditional Financial controls in place
to manage down spending it's if we're
overspending on another service area
section 151 officer I can say or cross a
variety of different surface areas we
just need to stop spending
um and to new oh no new contractual
arrangements or recruitment freeze can't
do that with homelessness because we
don't control the number of we don't
directly control the number of homes
that present as homelessness we can only
put measures in place to try and reduce
the numbers and to mitigate
and to mitigate
the the numbers that are coming through
the system
and Council case I just wanted to
respond a little bit more in the algae
we're not intending not to clean areas
to discourage people to come in fact
some of the areas that we don't clean is
because it's only as egress from the sea
it's not actually a public entrance onto
the beach but of course the tidal areas
the poles they're a vetmen all of the
really high used areas of course they'll
still be subject to the same cleaning
schedule but we're more talking about
places where they're not actually
naturally
um in high usage areas which which
really don't need to be cleaned as
regularly so it's not about discouraging
people from coming or anything like that
but it's also about protecting our own
interests and what we can do
realistically as a council and also
encouraging things like the Open Water
Swimming which I know you're quite
interested in
um so I just wanted to say you know I
didn't mean to come across crass with
how we've been trying to repudiate
claims but it's more about trying to get
the right balance basically between what
we can physically do and what we should
be doing as well so that was just wanted
to clarify that for you no thank you
very much much appreciated and um yeah
I'll take the point on
um about the extra 400 000 and I think
that's yeah sensible I
I think it is a serious risk though with
this winter that that number is gonna
escalate and escalate and escalate so
we'll have to keep our eye on it
councilor towning
um
we talked about the beaches and uh you
know
managing the better reducing the risk
out there for barbecues and such like
have we ever explored
the possibility of utilizing
an organization
to actually sponsor our beaches
you know
and then they pay us another body for
having that sponsorship for it and then
we utilize that money
because every time you say hey what
about some uh
enforcement we go nobody
and what we need to do is to explore
these areas of commercializing ourselves
a bit more
to reduce that risk to take all the uh
you know that that that positive let's
get out there and find someone who will
do it for us so I do know
was engaged into in talking to someone
locally about that and you do know Chris
that I've been involved in raising money
for the beaches okay uh
but you know I'm happy to to engage in
that area of commercializing ourselves
to get
that body in and reduce the risk of that
beach which I have seen regularly
happening
can't comment on what we've done in the
past unless the Matthew can but I can't
the chickens had some I'm assuming not
but it sounds like a a worthy suggestion
uh councilorant something I'm happy for
us to take back to our corporate
management team for further discussion
Council Hopkinson
thank you chair
um just on the algae
um people falling over Etc I see I know
he talks about you know rightly talks
about we've got to consider our
liability I wonder if there are also you
know maybe there are other ways we can
think about actually you know reducing
the actual number of people that are
following I know obviously people take
their own responsibility for that if I
wonder you know I mean I don't actually
know what is the signage and are we
designing that in-house and is it worth
I'm trying to rethink that and if there
are other alternatives to
you know collaboratively with the
community trying to get people to not do
I know it's not there's no perfect
solution but I wonder if there's a way
and just another question if it's okay
another one
um with the Jackie Baker's roof is that
the this is the roof of the um training
the um uh address that you've also
called the changing rooms yeah yeah and
so I just wonder who would be using that
if it was still usable
and what I mean are we are we
considering
you know repairing it I mean is that is
there a viable way to doing that
that's thank you counselor um in terms
of the algae I I need to look into that
yes I do agree actually that you know
having a more collaborative response the
prob not the problem but what we found
is and the few claims that we've had it
tends to be on slipways um not so much
the revetment all the steps we've had
some claims on the slipways which as we
know are designed really for launching
boats
um and
um some people do use them for dog
walking and so on so forth you know of
course we want people to enjoy our
coasts and our beaches and so on
um but we must be able to warn them of
the dangers that do arrive this is a
coastal area you know that isn't really
designed for people to go dog walking
because we're not just going to shut it
off so I do think that yes you're right
a more collaborative approach
um should be used I mean I I know that
Luke Glover in technical is working very
hard on algae
um and he's working very hard with
people like the environment agency with
our insurers with risk management and so
on so forth and looking at models from
other councils that have full shows see
what type of signage they can actually
use and is effective from my perspective
looking as an insurance person we look
to reduce the liability and that's my
remap Luke's going to look at it from a
technical point and I'm sure the beach
manager in the beach and coastal manager
will be looking it from a tourism and
from a local perspective so I think that
this isn't over by any stretch of the
imagination and I think that we are
trying a collaborative approach we don't
want to discourage people from using the
beach but we do want them to be safe all
right and I'll pass over to Matt in
terms of Jackie Bakers thank you
just further as well in relation to the
work that Luke's doing from a technical
perspective in the environment agency
when he starts taking forward Coastal
schemes moving forward he'll be looking
at opportunities where We've Got High
football areas where over the years some
of the slipways have become access to
the beach by default he will be looking
at when they put a new scheme in to look
at the the foreshore that there was
maybe an opportunity to put some sort of
proper steps in which were actually more
suitable for people gaining access so
you know like they are elsewhere it's
it's a massive piece of work but can be
picked up as part of those Coastal Works
whereas at the moment we couldn't just
do it independently it's not possible
with regards to Jackie Baker's there is
actually a group that's within the
organization that's looking at
opportunities for Jackie Baker's moving
forward in terms of wider schemes what
we could do with that site to make it
more user-friendly better facilities
whether we could get external funding to
deliver you know reinstate things like
the 4G pitch rather than the old astro
turf and part of that would be looking
at the building itself and whether
there's an opportunity for that because
it may not be the best location station
for it and repairing and replace it it
gets to replace the repair so it might
be part of a bigger scheme moving
forward depending on how that pans out
there's no limit in terms of what the
opportunities are Cricket football
hockey you know there are opportunities
and there used to be pitches up their
grass pitches and they used to and that
main pitch used to be used for hockey as
well and they Exist Elsewhere and
they're well used so but it's about
looking at what does the district need
because there's no point
um putting in a massive scheme when
we've exhausted opportunities elsewhere
within the district because more of the
sort of private sector have started
developing those type of arrangements
did you know that at one time tenet used
to run the largest hockey Festival in
Europe
they used to
yeah they used to the male and female
okay
um so just wrapping it up
um
the recommendation is to approve the
review of the corporate risks please can
I have a proposal and a seconder
proposed by councilor shrub and seconded
by councilor Garner unless I hear any
objection I take this as approved
yes
um an addition in addition to that we
had a recommendation to refer to
cabinets for
the
algae at the pspo and the homelessness
are we happy with that
proposed by Council sharp seconded by
councilor Garner unless I hear any
objection I will say this is approved
Fab that concludes the business for
tonight's meeting and to close meeting
closed at 2026 good night